Tonight, the
man who spent
decades helping run Donald
Trump's family
business, Allen Weisselberg,
could be on the verge
of pleading guilty for the second time,
this time to a perjury charge,
we are told.
The 76 year old
was the chief financial
officer of the Trump
Organization for decades.
He went to jail at Rikers
for about 100 days last year.
That was for his role
in running
a 15 year tax fraud scheme
at the Trump Organization.
Now, tonight,
there is new reporting
from The New York Times
and confirmed by CNN
that Weisselberg is in talks
to potentially plead guilty
to a perjury charge,
this time related to Trump's
civil fraud trial,
where he, Allen Weisselberg,
would have to admit
that he lied on the stand
during his own testimony.
The timing here is also key
as we are learning more
about this new reporting,
because right now
we're waiting on the judge in this case
to decide
what the penalty is,
essentially how much Donald Trump owes
or reminder,
the attorney general
in the closing arguments
after north of $370 million
and is a ruling
that could threaten Trump's
entire real estate empire.
I'm joined tonight by the senior
editor at Forbes, Dan Alexander,
who is the guest on this story,
because it was his reporting
that exposed
Weisselberg's alleged lies
under oath on the stand.
And then when you look at this
and we don't know, I should note
which statement exactly
it is
that that could potentially
go towards this perjury charge
if he does plead guilty here.
But you noted in your reporting
that there were emails and notes from him
that are believed to be
at the center of this.
What did you pick up on
and what you believe that he lied about
as he was kind of
trying to distance himself from
Trump's financial statements?
Yes, I remember the trial.
It was about Trump
lying about his net worth.
And one of the key
examples of that is that
Trump was claiming
that his penthouse was 30,000 square feet
when in fact it was 10,996 square feet.
And Allen Weisselberg was on the stand
and was trying to explain
that he really had
nothing to do with this.
And as he was making that claim,
it was obvious to me that he was lying.
I went back through our notes
and could track years of conversations
that he had had
with our reporters
where he was really focused
on the penthouse,
where he was trying to claim
that it was 30,000
square feet or even 33,000 square feet.
I think at one point Donald Trump had it
and that he was trying to claim
that it was wildly overvalued.
So this is clear documented stuff
that you can say,
you know, he's claiming one number.
The documents show another number
and he's lying.
You know,
you noted in that story
that you had documents
that prosecutors didn't have.
Did you hear from their
office after that?
So their office did
go back and look through documents
with the Trump Organization
and try to do an additional
sort of forensic look.
And they
put some paperwork in the docket
about that.
They did not come after us for anything
but everything that we have is out there.
You know, we've released tapes of Trump
lying about the size of his penthouse.
We've put out the notes
of Weisselberg's
conversations over the years.
All of this stuff has all been laid out
very clear.
It's a remarkable piece of journalism.
Dan Alexander, thank you for that.
And for more on this breaking story,
we have former federal prosecutor
Elie Honig here as well.
And you heard what Dan said there.
I mean, this is a groundbreaking article
that pretty flatly stated
that they believed Allen
Weisselberg had lied.
All of this is coming as Judge
Negron has not decided yet.
He said by the jury,
obviously that was yesterday,
wasn't definitive.
But but could that play a role
in why we haven't heard from him yet?
Absolutely.
If I'm in Judge and Gordon's
position here
and getting ready to issue
a big verdict and ruling
and now I hear this
and now we've all heard it,
that one of the key witnesses
committed perjury in front of me.
I slam on the brakes
and I say I'm not going to rule
until I know the specifics of this now.
I think it's likely the judge
probably discredited
Allen Weisselberg's testimony
anyway because it was contradicted
by so many of the facts
as Dan just laid out.
But you have to know this as a judge,
if you're going to issue a ruling
and if it turns out Weisselberg lied,
that's going to harm
the Trump Organization.
When it comes time for the verdict,
how could it bode
for Donald Trump himself?
It's a problem for Donald Trump
because he's going to be
on the receiving end of this verdict.
It is important, though,
there's an important detail
in the reporting
that Weisselberg's deal
that he's working on or towards
with prosecutors
does not
necessarily involve
Allen Weisselberg
cooperating against Donald Trump.
And that doesn't surprise me.
This guy is not in position to cooperate.
I've I've cooperated
some really bad guys.
But the problem is
when you have an inveterate liar
multiple times convicted,
if he takes this plea,
you can't put that person on the stand
and ask a jury to believe him.
And also when we talk
I mean, Allen Weisselberg
fiercely loyal to Donald Trump,
I should note.
But I think one thing we forget about,
which The New York Times noted tonight,
is that
he got a $2 million severance package
that required him
not to cooperate
with any law enforcement investigation
unless he was legally required.
That was stunning to me.
I've never heard of such a thing.
I don't think that's enforceable to say
you won't cooperate with law enforcement.
I mean, it certainly undermines
what prosecutors are trying to do.
I mean, unless legally required that,
I guess that could mean a subpoena
for trial or anything.
But that's a shocking detail
to put into a severance agreement
in addition to the amount.
So they're clearly Trump
and his people
are trying to keep weisselberg
in the fold here,
I think,
because they're worried about him
slipping.
Yeah, And I should note
he has not actually agreed to this yet.
He's just in talks to potentially do so.
It could fall apart.
We've seen it happen
with other plea deals.
L.A.
Witness or Ali Hoenig,
thank you, helped me with this.
So if I saw something,
he would be a great witness.
Instead,
I do want to turn now
to conservative attorney
and one of Donald Trump's
fiercest critics
who anyone who watches
the source would know
George Conway is here.
George,
I mean, if this does come to fruition
for Allen Weisselberg,
the theme here would be in
both guilty pleas that
he was lying on Donald Trump's behalf,
would it not?
Yes.
And it's actually not surprising
because that's
what Donald Trump does to people.
And we've seen numerous circumstances
where Trump has gotten people to lie
or obstruct justice
or perform illegal acts
to protect him,
even sometimes
when he hasn't even asked them to do it,
they understand what he wants them to do.
I mean, you see all these people
who are indicted,
including his own chief of staff
at the White House
and in Georgia, we've seen Michael Cohen.
We've seen Weisselberg previously.
We it's just up
Donald Trump is just a cloud of
deception.
And he is he creates a culture
of lying and deception
and illegality wherever he goes.
And if you are associated with him,
you have to be very, very careful.
You're taking a risk.
I mean, there are lawyers who
who are losing their licenses,
are threatening,
are being threatened
with losing their licenses
for defending him.
And it just
it never, ever stops with him.
He asks
he expects people to do
illegal things for him.
Here's what I'm confused by,
which is Allen
Weisselberg was in jail
for 100 days in Rikers.
You know, just one year ago.
He went the beginning of 2023
when he testified on the stand.
After that,
there were
emails and documents to back up.
You know, or to contradict what he
was saying. Why would he lie?
It's just beyond me.
I think that
he's doing it because he's wanted
he wants to protect his boss
or he doesn't
want his boss to get mad at him.
He doesn't want
retribution from his boss.
I mean, it's these are,
you know,
the people who work for Donald
Trump are kind of like
abused family members in some ways.
They they they
they shudder at
the thought of displeasing him.
They're afraid of retaliation
and they instinctively end up
doing the wrong thing
because that's what Donald Trump
expects them to do.
The district attorney
in Manhattan, Alvin Bragg,
may be the only person
to bring a case against Trump this year.
I mean,
we don't know what's going to happen
with the other indictments,
but we know that Trump's team
is focused on slowing them down.
Could could something like this
strengthen his hand?
Bragg's hand going into that trial?
I think indirectly.
I mean, this does not directly impact
the charges that are involved in
in the case that
D.A.
Bragg has brought.
That's the it's actually
the falsification of documents
relating to the hush money
that Donald Trump paid
through Michael Cohen
to Stormy Daniels, the porn star.
So this doesn't directly relate to that.
But I think it's a very,
very important
warning to any witness
who's called to testify
in that case
on either side
that they better not lie,
because if they lie, then,
you know,
they could end up like right weisselberg
at Rikers or someplace
unpleasant like that.
Yeah, it's a remarkable development
in this story.
George Conway, thank you for that.
I mean, as we just
we don't know what's
going to happen here with this
and whether or not he's taking it.
But but big picture, how do you see it?
Well,
I think George makes a good point there.
I think that this actually will
tie Trump's hands a bit
at the Manhattan DA's trial,
because if they were planning
on calling Allen Weisselberg
to say, for example,
Donald Trump
had nothing to do with the way
these hush money payments were logged,
it was me, the CFO,
and it was Michael Cohen,
their star witness.
He can't do that now.
He's neutralized now
because he denied Trump
a potentially helpful.
What exactly it takes.
Allen Weisselberg
off the table
as a potential defense witness.
Like I said before,
you're not calling him as a prosecutor.
The guy's
going to have at least one conviction
and probably two for perjury
if he takes this plea.
But it also means he can't come in
as some sort of surprise witness
to try to take the case in Trump's favor.